under the leadership of their new
district attorney Rachel Rollins suff
County decided to stop Prosecuting
criminals who are accused of most
nonviolent misdemeanors including
disorderly conduct and shoplifting the
recent policy change in suffa County
imposing a presumption of
non-prosecution for nonviolent
misdemeanor offenses decrease the
likelihood of subsequent criminal
justice involvement in other words if
you let criminals get away with
shoplifting they're less likely to get
in trouble with the law in the future
and in leftwing circles this is known as
restorative justice and officials in
Boston said it was proof that their idea
had worked success what no one seemed to
grasp at these universities is that this
is the exact result you would expect
when you legalize shoplifting and it's
not a good result like it's not
surprising that shoplifters don't get in
trouble with the law anymore if you stop
Prosecuting them for petty crimes if you
don't punish people for crimes fewer
people will be punished for crimes